bootleg cat podcast special guest in
here Malcolm Mays welcome sir
people who don't know uh I know you from
snowfall all right all right which is
obviously one of the more legendary
television shows of the last I don't
know forever yeah yeah it's one of them
ones it's one of them ones um but I did
not know that you made music so what
were you doing first acting or the music
it was always both so I'm um I came up
at a church that was in the middle of
the 20s called first African Methodist
Episcopal Fang okay
um out of it came 1500 or Nothing so
rants in them yeah all from that same
church Jammy and so I've always been
musically inclined it's just everybody
else is better than it around me right
so I didn't think like you know when you
when you hanging around goats you often
think that your talent is minimized
right but then you also get to Stepping
around other people and you're like wait
hold up I might have something I'm
actually like they're so amazing that
I'm better than everybody else well I
could be your recipe right if you put
the work in in time but I've always been
doing music I've been a songwriter since
I was 15 I got my first placement at 16
years old what was your placement man I
ain't wrestling and got that I got that
for me oh word yeah they did it was a
blessing it was um I think it was on a
TV show or something
like a 90210 or something like that yeah
my first song independently it was dope
so obviously living in La a lot of
people come here to start acting what
was the origination of you like being an
actor and like actually making a career
out of it oh [__] my mama bro like mama
grandma uh my community even my church
like in church plays you know my mom
always was like trying to find different
ways to keep me distracted off the
streets and it didn't work but she tried
her best and this was one of the things
that's that always
um stuck Wendy Raquel Robinson I gotta
give her a flower she had a school in
the hood for acting
um Amazing Grace Conservatory which is
still active to this day and basically
she gives grants out to certain kids who
she believes is talented to kind of
Foster and give them a conservatory
level of training right and um at a cost
which was no cost for some people to be
honest and that's produced like I think
the dude who was in Moonlight and like
me yeah she she it'll produce music or
everybody everybody so you came out of
there yeah I did and before that it was
Faith acting so it was Faith acting then
AGC and they were kind of the same so it
was there and then um yeah it just kind
of kept me out out the way well it tried
to keep me out the way yeah
um how because I the ACT obviously I'm
involved in the music industry and the
music industry
is such it's a lot of it's like hitting
the lotto but for whatever reason the
acting game to me feels like even more
difficult to get like into oh yeah
numerically I mean if you look at the
people first of all music don't have no
Union so that's not I probably just
everyone moves to L.A and like it's like
not all of y'all getting in the movies
bro oh yeah no I think it's less than
one percent of the SAG Union works
that's crazy it's a job a year and I've
been blessed enough to always work with
that didn't come from no like you know
knowing nobody I want nobody nephew or
son or nothing I was just me and and
blessed enough to have people see me
working along the way so what was your
first big break on the acting side first
Big Break [__] well I made my first big
break to me was when I made my first
feature I was 17 years old I wrote
director start in it because I didn't
know no better right and um I won this
Grant from Panavision I was like 17
years old it was supposed to be for
college students but I didn't know
and they gave me this big ass film
camera and so I had to learn how to like
cut film like like my fingers you shot
your own [__] like yeah yeah like really
I was on super 16. I'm shooting my first
feature I'll start in it directed it um
but I always had a love for Cinema I
always had a love for music right so I
just that was like a mode of expression
for me like even when you say like oh
the music industry or the film industry
that should be weird to me because
that's not my I don't have like actor
friends I didn't get active friends till
later I had like friends who like we
throw going away parties and those going
away parties just to turn themselves in
jail yeah that's my friends like so I
didn't even as I was being successful
even when like I'm going to Telluride or
whatever and the homies ain't never
heard of that [__] right you know what
I'm saying but like I'm talking about
you know Bernardo Bertolucci you know
[__] don't really know what the [__]
I'm talking about but you know they
supported me they love me I always got
love so I just kept doing it but the
industry the commodification of art I
still don't get that [__] I don't know
how you navigate it I don't know how my
manager Chris Cornish navigated I don't
know how [__] do that I just make [__]
and been blessed enough and people like
it yeah well sometimes but like really I
just I bother [__] right because I
ain't [__] is scarier and ain't no no
scary ain't nothing scarier than death
so I'll be pressing like I'm making my
[__] I'm going and if people like it
they like it so
um how did you initially get into
snowfall obviously John Singleton was
behind I mean God Rest the soul rest in
peace to John Singleton
um but you're obviously very imperative
early in the show yeah what was the
process of getting on his radar and
getting casted in that show well I had
known John since I was 16 17 years old
because of that movie I told you right
so when I made it I was also working at
Sony pictures under the head of physical
production named Gary Martin he gave me
the opportunity to learn the business of
filmmaking because he I was bothering
him so he was like you know it was an
internship that I found I snuck on a lot
right that's crazy yeah it was crazy it
was really wild out here you know I was
ditch I was going to summer school at
Hamilton and ditching so you were
interning on the movie lot yeah but
nobody really knew how old I was so they
just like let me do [__] and I knew what
I was talking about but they didn't know
I was a kid kid so I was getting checks
like 16 15 years old that were looking
like nice like not crazy right or
something
you like [__] I'm up and my family
living in a section I'm like I'm up so
for me making that feature film there
were other people like Gary Martin who
had built the careers of minority
filmmakers he's a white dude look like
Santa Claus right but he always enabled
black Latino and female filmmakers from
the 9 like Robert Rodriguez like all him
and John and he thought that I reminded
him of John and John he would tell John
I got this kid I got this kid but until
I made my first feature John wasn't
trying to hear it so when I finally made
my first feature got on the front of New
York Times John was like okay I'll
listen to this kid you feel me and um we
clicked because he did know who Bernardo
Bertolucci was right he did know you
know what what burger stand not to go to
in South Central Los Angeles and he knew
books and he knew music and he like
people don't know John on the record
label and the first person he ever
signed was um I was an eight dog crazy
yeah that's like he been that [__] like
it's it's always been intertwined it's
never really been separated and you know
like if you know the history of L.A you
know was he also working with Coolio
yeah at some point yeah yeah he got he
really go crazy like I had um I had the
music music director dude um for the
show on uh the white dude from from
Compton what's his name yeah yeah Jon
Stewart he for real I ain't gonna lie he
been outside like he's been outside
right but yeah no that so so you're like
a real just film geek I mean you got to
be a geek about this [__] to really like
put your own movie out as a kid I mean
[__] I'm like that with music too like I
like my like so are you editing your own
movie I did at that time yeah now now
it's like it's too easy like I'm saying
when you're like so like back in the day
did you have Final Cut like back in the
day it was Avid and now you still have
Avid but back then it was these massive
systems that you had to edit on just
like like music right here and it's like
no it used to be crazy now anybody can
buy a little red box from Guitar Center
and but Just Like Music everything used
to be tape everything used to be analog
you had to cut it right if you wanted
that analog feel so I was actually I
remember my first film I cut like on
like a like a like a star you were
actually like studying the film and then
the next film I did like on Avid which
is like ingesting these massive things
um I shot on film I did all that I've
done my work like I really been out here
probably didn't have to but but that was
I loved it when you love some [__] you
don't even know that you're supposed to
be doing certain things to industrialize
to um solidify a career or political I
never did the politics very well even in
music like that's why it took me so long
to transfer over and do this EP which is
on Street journals volume one June 23rd
and um you you know I got these big
features and everybody's like oh my God
who was on your EP like bro if I gotta
tell you off camera because it's a
surprise you're here to promote it who's
on the EP man can I tell them where am I
holding that it's a big one
you can tell well you can't you can't
put it in though you got to beep it you
gotta you gotta beep it will beep it so
my the next single I'll play it for you
it's little baby oh [__]
and then the next one me and Wally we
just got a video today oh shout out to
Wally yeah it's crazy it's gonna go
crazy like it's suffice on you people to
go crazy like it's really different damn
that's a pretty uh
that's a pretty serious feature to get
is this your first CP this is my second
one the first one was red flags it was
red flags was more like a um like a like
a gritty r b
would you consider like your movie
career is helping you fund your music
career now because obviously everything
but everything right like because I you
know my movie career you know acting I
make a bag that's for the family
um but I make people don't know like I'm
Diversified I have a real estate
investment trust I got like at some
point I had an equity stake in the
luxury car business during the pandemic
because you know all the finesses and
drug dealers wanted to rent cars oh yes
they did I made a bunch of money doing
that but when when you say make a bunch
of money it's not like a flex it's like
I would I would I took I just basically
took money I was gonna go spend to go
buy a dumb car and and went and invested
in a company that I had a bunch of cars
so that like whatever's not on the lot I
would just use that so that was fun
because I got to experiment with cars
and see what I liked it's never really
motivated by me trying to like you know
look fly it's more so me like how do I
not lose this money right so I do that I
gotta um but that's all just business
ventures to make sure that my mom my
grandma my son my my seed has something
but the music was always just a passion
that I love to do and I don't want to
lose money and Chris got Christians you
know he just left Empire right to [__]
with me you know I'm managed by him and
Brent uh Brent's managers which is Thai
based in and Jane Andrews so like a lot
of people have banked on me you know
Venice music group is Distributing yeah
that's a distro company ever they don't
my friend uh tweeze over there yeah and
um and essentially they like they just
help you if you independent so a lot of
people taking time out putting Sweat
Equity into me and I just don't want him
to look stupid so like I gotta I gotta
follow through now yeah so I put [__]
I'm not ashamed of it I took every
dollar I had from all of these different
Ventures and said I'm banking on myself
with this music [__] so when I was
talking to glasses I'm like bro you know
you know cause you're one of the few
left real la media outlets for hip-hop
right like we are we are in a dire state
right we got you we got community in
them which uh homegrown radio show home
radio of course DJ head and of course
like Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck is
that man
um but then it's like Gina when she's
not on no jumper I guess and like she's
not on no jumper now I think Gina just
started her uh own thing for her
apartment she should but she but she's
been doing that like she's been hard
like Gina's though she's all and the DJ
her and her the DJ trying to be doing
[__] so like and they should go crazy
yeah so uh West Coast Conference the
name of their show they were doing I
don't think it's happening anymore
though oh okay well do you see what I'm
saying we don't have a place to go all
the play all the outlets is on the East
Coast or in the South so for sure the
East Coast got a sewed up so this is
important to me because I'm like well
where did the little homies go tap into
really because you know hip-hop you know
music history you know like you've been
outside and you really love this [__] so
I was like man who do I talk to who do I
go tell that hey look I make music I'm
out here and it's not bad who do you go
to that goes hey this [__] this [__] oh
right y'all should check this out
there's only like three people and I'm
not going I ain't going to [__] on
nobody but I'm not going to the
you know I'm not you're not gonna catch
me on nobody like no defense to nobody
respectfully on how to get their money
but certain platforms you're not gonna
see me on because I don't I'm from a
certain element and I got a code I'm not
doing it right and so it makes it very
difficult so this was very important to
me I appreciate you coming through man
really important you're this is really
important well I appreciate it so you
know so the EP is June 23rd that's when
it's dropped June 25th dropping off the
the surprise single feature with the
music video and the EP all at once
um we got away from John you were
telling me about how you would uh well
he taught me how to invest in myself
okay so he he had originally taken you
serious once he saw you invest in myself
you did this movie your own feature and
all that so how does that spiral off so
what ends up happening is he goes I'm
gonna get you in the USC Film School
okay because like that's the dream is to
have John Singleton walk you into the
dean of USC film score and go which was
essentially what happened
um but I was still outside
um I think there was some and I always
say this I think I was he has a son
who's a wonderful human being and a
great you know director and Creator and
visual assist himself but their
relationship was tense
um and at that time it was tense it was
great after that but I think I at that
time I didn't have me and my pops wasn't
really you know he wasn't really around
at that moment so John kind of filled in
and I kind of filled in for that
relationship that he was not repairing
with his son in my opinion and I could
be wrong and we kind of like bumped
heads a lot because it it meant a lot to
us I didn't know that until later I just
thought he was trying to be my daddy
right I'm like [__] I don't like I
don't really want to hear none of that
yeah but at the end of the day he wanted
me to go to school and study filmmaking
but I wanted to study the business of
filmmaking because I knew how to make
movies right and he thought
and he was right that [__] was that's
not what he walked me in there to do
right and so we bumped head pretty bad
and we you know I ended up you know in
back in the streets again doing some
things and and he kind of was
disappointed and we kind of like got
into it and then you know we ended up
rerouting back to each other when I
auditioned because Kim Kim Hardin who's
his longtime casting director auditioned
on snowfall on snowfall she brought me
in originally the Tupac and then she was
like you dope like I need to [__] with
you for the Tupac movie yeah he was
going to do his Tupac movies I have the
original draft of his Tupac movie John
Singleton has a Tupac movie he has a
Tupac movie and the opening is
did that movie ever get made
because the Tupac movie we got was
decent let's not even do that it was
decent I would say it was decent I think
I think the Tupac movie we got it does
it does get some unwarranted hey I'm a
real [__] like I love any boom like he
did a lot for my section you know I
think he gets unwanted hey I actually
thought like when I saw it I was like I
mean I thought they casted the [__] out
of Tupac but we know that Tupac's biopic
deserved the same level of NWA residents
even more I'll say that he deserved a
Gandhi level right a Malcolm X level for
sure he was that big of a of a in that
level of cinema right and that doesn't
mean that Benny couldn't do it but the
budget limited and all that that's what
I'm saying yeah I just think there was
like budget issues yeah you could kind
of tell it's like it should have gotten
the same respect as like Ali or
something you know yeah and so my my big
homie um uh legs recipes you know lucky
was right hands with Benny Boom so he's
helped out in the section A Lot shot the
Waka Flocka video in our section all
that so I show him no I actually thought
it was like like knowing all the
restraints and [__] I thought it was I
thought it was solid and I thought that
the no I can't now I can't say that I
don't feel that way but I respect the
kids the kid who played Tupac though
look just like him he Jesus Kev you're
such a Hip-Hop Hip-Hop [__] just like
he look like him
that's like real hip-hop [__] to say
it's like are we sure I wasn't around
your mom Bradley but but you never know
what blessings you get from losing so
right that that Kim was like I need to
bring you in for something I think you'd
be the great the great as a lead for she
brought me into the lead of snowfall so
they you got brought in to be Franklin
Saint initially oh I screen test okay
yeah I was asked the screen test yeah
like I went in like and John didn't even
recognize me until the first audition he
was like holy [__] that's my he was like
that's my [__] son I just think it's
amazing he's like where have you been he
was like it was crazy it was a beautiful
reunion full circle moment oh man I
never forget it was Mother's Day I just
seen my um it was really tough for me at
that time like we were my family was
going through it I put all our business
out but it was Mother's Day and I just
seen my mother and my grandmother in a
very compromising situation like they
were hiding like
[__] was on first floor of an apartment
hiding the air mattress in the bathroom
type [__] you know on Mother's Day and
the next day was my audition for so far
and you knocked it out the park
obviously I did and then but I think
that the studio just wanted to go
another way because the two creators are
actually John Singleton and Erica Erica
Mario who's from Downey and um he never
gets enough credit for creating snowfall
it was him and John's initial idea yeah
John's like you know the name you know
yeah just the name and put their DNA
together is what made the show and then
there's this um a showrunner what I'm
not going to mention who was kind of put
in position as a company man to kind of
manage them because they were they were
new to television and by the end of the
situation
um I just feel like uh a lot of the
decision making was not left up to John
and you know to my from from you know
for whatever better or worse but because
of that
um
certain things happen and that's fine
I'm okay with it because I think that
God works how he works the only thing I
would say is that gave me my mentor back
like we got to get back cool and that
leadership and that foundation and then
and then Sundays that I missed and that
and being up under him and learning in
history and just everything more than
just filming television it was just a
beautiful like thing and I the only
thing I I missed that I wish I could
have done was become a big enough star
to to to give back to him like he's
giving us so many stars for sure and
respect and love to them but he never
got the treatment that Scorsese got
right he never got the tree [__] he
didn't even get to see what snowfall
became no he didn't and and tomorrow in
my opinion I just wish he would have had
his Leo his Robert De Niro right you
know whoever his his part like the guy
who's booming because he put him on come
back and make all his filmmaking dreams
come true so that's my only regret right
right right right right right you know I
mean it ended up being like a greatly
casted show like yeah that everybody in
this show can act that [__] uh the
Idris dude did a great job like I didn't
even know he was from the UK until I
think I saw all interview after season
two and I was like this [__] kid's
from London no damn since the star hands
down like listen the original people who
were screen testing for for breakfast
and the Uncle Jerome uh was such a good
Caster oh yeah first of all Eamon Joseph
is a different level about he's a
different animal okay he's a different
animal same Beast like he's really what
Kobe be talking about that's him but
when I speak of dancing dancing earned
that amongst like he didn't just win
that against regular actor [__] he
went he wanted against the best of the
best out there like Kofi sirbo was up
for that role like I was a like it's
certain people you know like get busy I
heard like Dub C helped him with his
like West Coast style yeah dub was there
to do the training and um you know you
didn't help him at all but hey this
house of course I did but I but I never
took no credit because you know dub was
there every day but I just but initially
like when we were just like people don't
even remember
YG was originally Kevin oh I didn't know
that yeah and I remember right before
bro got you know he was in the studio
and got hurt yeah and then the studio
kind of freaked out I think and wait so
YG was supposed to be in show and then
he got shot and then things I don't know
what but like after he got hurt he
wasn't Kevin no more oh wow and then it
was Kofi that's crazy that's real [__]
that's how this [__] go bro this is like
this whole I did not know why she was
supposed to be in a snowfall oh man
listen Kofi was Kofi and I were up for
Franklin hope he ended up being the
leader um Queen sugar they moved me to
Leon I was Leon at some point however be
the lead to Leon to being to being Kevin
like then they made Kevin a bigger it
was crazy but you know for whatever the
reason that's what it was but what I'm
saying is damson is a star and I and
he's also my friend in a in a good dude
like he just he fun he have a good time
but it's funny because I don't even
think people have really realized how
entertaining he is yet you know but but
it will come and I just met him at the
uh Tyler the Creator show and he was
super nice super nice guy yeah he's a
fun guy he was just there by himself
enjoying the Tyler show yeah that's
dancing dancing like that he he's really
a Charming funny dude what's up y'all we
gotta stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our good friends at my
bookie that's right it is NBA Finals you
gotta Hammer the Nuggets I don't know
they might sweep the the heat I would
look at the
like serious odds on that go to my
bookie right now let's get some money
man all right baseball of course is in
full effect we got Stanley Cup finals
NFL seasons on the way sign up at
mybookie.ag right now use the promo code
bootleg and you will get that first
deposit bonus
all right look I don't care where you're
at you can go to mybookie.ag Let's
gamble on some sports they got the
casino you can do live Blackjack you can
do live roulette craps you could do all
kinds of slots and of course bet on the
NBA Finals bet on the NHL uh Stanley Cup
finals crazy shots of the Vegas golden
knights that's what I'm rooting for and
of course baseball season man all right
so look right now mybookie.ag use that
promo code bootleg uh and sign up when
you do use uh that promo code they're
going to give you a first deposit bonus
straight to your account free money all
right mybookie.ag go do that also got to
give a shout out to our family at Blue
chew that's right ladies and gentlemen
it's getting hot outside that means
I don't know what that means it's just
hot so I feel like when it's hot people
want to [__] more right so you know
fellas if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it happens to the best of us
I'm sure maybe you are old maybe you are
dealing with stress at work maybe you
don't want to sleep with the same lady
that you're married to over and over
need a little extra motivation to get
that thing stayed up you know what I
mean go to bluetooth.com use the promo
code bootleg and they'll send it
straight to your door three-month supply
of Bluetooth for free all right now does
Bluetooth work yes it does you're gonna
get a free month supply to be able to
see for yourself blue shoe.com promo
code bootleg uh now if you don't know
what it is it is the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis but in a
chewable form and you do not have to go
to a doctor's appointment all right you
do everything online you don't have to
go sit at a doctor's office and talk to
some old man in a lab coat about your
dick issues not necessary anymore in
2023 all right so go to Bluetooth sign
up with that promo code bootleg get a
month supply for free let's get back to
the interviews when you get the script
and you realize your guy is about to get
killed off what's that like as an actor
I don't feel [__] [__] from the streets
that [__] I'm just wondering I was glad
to get my family out the hood right
thank you for the money FX I was
wondering when I watched like my
favorite shows right and like you'll see
like one of these beloved characters get
killed like on the actor side when they
get that script and they're like oh
wow so Kev I don't know if you know this
I'm black
we die in everything
so so I'm just used to this no I'm just
kidding um I knew already right so you
had an idea that John well listen
there's certain things that I'm just not
going to talk about right now because I
I want to I don't want it to overshadow
what I'm doing with music what I'm doing
with film and television because when I
talk about that I want to talk about it
from a place of pure Truth for [__]
can't say I'm hating right so I gotta
win first but the the way that I could
say without being a snitch ass
[__] is being like other things
happen some real situations happen that
I didn't agree with how certain people
handled them John went to bat for me and
they found a way to be like hey like
we're not sure if we want to keep them
and John Candyman was like do you want
me to fight for you do you want to stay
on and John and I had so many we had
movies with Netflix going we had all
types of [__] going on like a movie like
we had all types of things like writing
and directing going on and so he was he
was like do you want me to to go to bat
for you and I and I was like no I don't
want to be where I'm not wanting right
and he's like well it's not that they
don't want you they just want to you
know they wanna they wanna get they want
to they're scared get you out of here
because you know whatever and I said
I'll be all right I'm straight bro I
don't I'm good and I was good I ended up
as a lead on raising Canyon so and for
me other actors they operate out of fear
because it's just like music like you
you know when people come bring in your
mixtape and [__] like they trying so
hard they love this [__] so hard they
work so hard and they don't get nothing
back from it you have one opportunity to
rap in front of calf you got one
opportunity to get in front of like
Kanye or somebody and do your [__]
and then that could change your whole
life
but I've been blessed enough to to know
my Divine ordainment like I would people
love me at home bro like where I'm from
I'm solid I'm I'm I could be on the I
could be down on down digging the dirt
and [__] respect me because of what
I've done in real life right my mama
loved me my Grandma loved me my section
loved me you feel me so
whether I book a role or not first of
all [__] know I'm cold with this movie
[__]
as you can see if I want to rap I could
rap good right I've seen God do whatever
I really want to do so everything is
just timing every but I feel bad for
other people because there's a
desperation and it's sad because people
take advantage of that well you're in
like a great position as a musical
artist because you do have
like a a real career a very thriving
acting career thank you man well and
there's a strike right now right so like
yeah how's that so for people who don't
understand because it is not working
yeah they not they out of work because
all we do is hear about this Rider
strike my uh you know my kid goes to
school in Burbank so you know so some of
his friends uh like parents are like uh
stuntman or yeah everybody is Gang [__]
so I'm so nobody is working bro let me
break this [__] down for you it's gang
[__] when you get in the union they
taxing your ass you don't even want to
be in the union they like hey bro sir
you're with the writers I'm with writing
d uh I think I'm a DJ I'm not sure sag
no I mean are you like you you agree
with the writers going on strike like
it's uh bro this gang [__] it don't
matter okay like it's gangbanging yeah
so like if if they strike everyone
strikes well yes well
yes now and thank God but it's not
always been like that there's like inner
things fighting but we're all coming
together because we all got the same
plight now the problem is that profits
have expanded massively egregiously
um and they in in the compensation has
remained the same much like an American
culture with like the um minimum wage
everything minimum wage is raised to
like two something twelve dollars it
does not it does not reflect inflation
right at all inflation is like I don't
know 10x or some [__] and then the
minimum wage is moved up a few cents or
whatever that's the same thing that's
happened with writers now for me I'm
from a place where like one writer's
check that it is right now can change my
whole life and everybody's life where
I'm from so it's hard for me to relate
as an individual but as a body and a
group of people who are trying to set a
standard so that egregious acts aren't
Happening by people at the top I gotta
support it it's true yeah the math is
math it is what it makes sense it makes
sense why they're striking it makes
sense and they need to so for you is is
your stars filming put to a whole
I didn't know if you were in the middle
of shooting or like well well we was
literally the day I was supposed to go
back to shoot like they was like wait
wait hold up but a lot of the scripts
were already written so we may still go
back because everything's written right
which means we're technically in the
clear for some of the scripts this is
where it gets tricky when so this is
where it gets tricky because
the most gangster of all the unions
ISC and um the truckers like the the
truck dude should be driving the trucks
[__] they they have a we don't cross
picking lines policy it's mandatory it's
gang banging so even though they are
contractually obligated to show up to
work if W.J sag or DJ show up and they
like form a picket line at any
production they won't cross they ain't
Crossing it so the secret is and I'm
probably snitching too much but it is
what it is if they if we can get to you
we gonna get on your ass and they're not
Crossing so [__] get stopped you feel me
and that does affect everybody's pocket
because then nobody's working
Productions Get slowed down things ain't
happening I've been blessed enough to
have been making a massive pivot or not
even a pivot but I was doing music well
you can focus on music a little bit more
now oh yeah I got the you see I got man
when I played this right I'm look I'm
baking all I have on music and at first
it sounded stupid to everyone around me
because they don't understand right but
when you come from nothing you wrote in
the dice bro you going in and now it
looks like I'm brilliant because my
homies ain't working and you are and
you're able to work on this other thing
you got going correct that's the beauty
of being independent like I funded my
own [__] Bro can't nobody tell me stop
and quite frankly like okay I'm in
solidarity with the writers and actors
and all that but this gives me time to
work on my own spec my own movies my own
music my own TV my own the show euron is
at the same show Joey Badass is on yes
it is that's my brother we gotta we got
a record too how about I say you guys
got to do a record we got a whole we got
a whole types of [__] he's a great actor
oh yeah now he turned it into a sex
symbol too you know
I was at the [__] mall
cologne oh yeah I can't wait till I get
mine can't look under underground rap
homie is over here Bowman dabson had
Calvin Klein first thing I did was take
a picture of him be like look at your
goofy I'm so happy for him and then you
know Joey got Paco rabong you know the
homies is really getting into these
spaces I'm like I can't wait to get mine
I might be a little too rough though but
they they should look fly okay you're a
part of the power Universe now is there
power the universe or snowfall what are
we even talking about bro like you don't
want me to answer that question because
look first of all I I love fifth Fitness
fifth is a beautiful yeah just let me do
my [__] bro don't let me get because
look I'm not scared of getting fired and
that's why everybody that's why I don't
do podcasts right but I'm [__] with
you so I'm gonna tell you the truth 50
no I love him and he's built Something
Beautiful he creates Stars yeah for sure
movies don't create Stars right like TV
creates stores yeah and 50 be doing that
so shout out to him in my personal
opinion
power did something interesting
internationally and something that was
accessible for a large amount of people
but bar for bar like what are we talking
about snowfall is a bar for bar snowfall
is a different level it's one of the uh
yeah now if you ask me snowfall versus
raising Canaan we gonna have some
conversations okay because raising
Canaan is top tier filmmaking like shout
out to Sasha Penn it's different over
there shout out to like my whole cast is
like look ain't look it's tough because
amen
um dancing you know Gail Bean like they
really go crazy Isaiah like everybody
over there go crazy even their co-stars
like right even the who plays damson's
mom is a legendary Right even the dude
who played is that there's a legendary
but when I talk about patina Miller
I love dancing damson is one of the best
young actors we have patina Miller Tony
award-winning Miller she's she might be
one of the best when it's all said and
done ever wow and we and everybody
around her Haley Kilgore Tony nominated
crying every episode that's some real
ass stem Tony's is them real acting I'm
just it's different bro and you know we
got then we got then we got London Brown
who's giving a stellar performance then
we have Makai Curtis so I'm the youngest
thing on our cast Makai is murdering
everyone in the power Universe respect
to everybody else makai's acting when
you look at him you think he 50. crazy
that's a Suburban kid yeah he ain't
nothing 50 about him in real life y'all
hear him be like that's 50. right it's
different on that side the texture the
clothing
um Frank who does our clothing is is
different right the texture is diff if
you watch bar for bar
ah it's close power might have them with
raising Canyon raising Canaan I think so
I gotta be honest with you I I am the
most unhipped to the power Universe
person alive it's not your fault I'm
gonna tell you the truth I just never
got Stars I never got the streaming and
then I'm like a wire dude bro I never
watched power until I was only yeah
facts I just I always like I started to
watch season one right when you get into
it you're hooked so I watched the first
two episodes of the first season of
power and when the chick was like
playing with herself in the back seat
crazy that's the first episode bro I was
just like I was like imagine watching it
I'm like like I swear by the wire that's
my favorite show ever because it's one
of the best shows of all time and then
snowfall just sucked me in bro pause
that [__] was amazing but if we're being
real like my mom he was also on the wire
is Leaps and Bounds better than
snowballs well I think the wire is the
best show ever it's top tier what it's
literally I think it's the wire go ahead
and then Sopranos and Breaking Bad okay
so I would go
see I don't see me I go The Wire
and then I'd go I just think it's the
wire and everything else I think that we
have to Subs we have to yeah essentially
it's like everything else not even worth
it but it's the wire and then everything
else yeah Rome was pretty great though
what was that wrong oh you know I never
watched Rome that was on HBO too right
HBO got got hitters bro they got some
all of them man HBO for whatever reason
whatever's in the water over there man
they don't [__] around when it comes to
their shows in the original one Game of
Thrones was crazy no it's crazy homicide
um uh the the original Network show that
the creators of the wire created which
was homicide something
um was actually one of the best shows on
television for years and I never watched
it but I heard about it it was hard and
West Wing hard you know Awesome's dope
that's Oz was dope like yeah they got
hitters like but if we really talking
about it snowfall is really fun and it
has great actors you know but when it
comes to the wire it's different so the
thing about snowfall is let me know
because you weren't on the show at this
time when the episode happens last
season
and they rebounded with the episode
where everybody was [__] up at the
wedding I love that episode but when the
episode happens where they get locked up
in the basement and there's a [__]
was it a grizzly bear or a tiger or
something that's when they lost me when
that happened I was just like yeah it
went too far but but this is what
happens look I'm not gonna speak too
heavy on that show because there's too
many people I love and care about
benefiting from that show and until I'm
as big as that show right I have nothing
to say about that show but love the
writing out of that was really shaky
that was ridiculous and everybody can
agree that was ridiculous so let's just
leave it there because you never saw
that and I like the way it ended I
thought it ended well season five was a
nice which is hard to do for a
television season four was tough though
when that happened I was just like wait
a minute I'ma say no comment for it
there's a random white dude living in
the hood with a [__] tiger in his
[__] basement bro no comment and they
escaped listen I think you are speaking
for the people yeah
but I also don't want to make this a
snowfall show like there's my
wife my wife she loved that [__] but my
wife like loves you know she likes like
[__] but that's what I mean is like
nobody bro let's keep it a bug nobody
watched The Wire when it was first out
except for drug dealers nobody sold
drugs and critics it was like the nerdy
show to watch it's almost yes succession
right now yes and then years later I
feel like finally the the general
population are like getting hip to
succession where like the TV nerds have
kind of been hit for like four or five
years yeah they're the early adopters
it's like knowing the wire was like that
yeah it had to end for people to be like
let me go back and get the DVD it's the
Great American novel right it's the [__]
that everybody knows is great but it's
too long so no nobody read it
was like my favorite character in TV for
the best ever yeah and like in my
opinion like yeah and there's you know
like I said I I don't want to make this
that show but in real life I think
snowfall did it uh it was a great
entertainment did his job it was very
entertaining one of the most
entertaining shows on television hands
down in depths is one of the most times
people and so was aiming there how
involved um is 50 in like the day-to-day
like do you like here he sets it up he
set it up he was very involved day to
day when we begin and get the show
rolling but then it's like bro I set it
up y'all got to do what you got to do
and really truly it becomes the
mechanizations of everybody who's in key
positions behind the scenes such as
Sasha and the showroom
um you know we got to attached has he
listened to the music have you sent him
any records oh 50
um 50 you know what's up 50 know what's
up but he like you know we gonna see
what's going on that'd be crazy you get
50 at least do a skit or something I
know 50 my dog but you know what bro I'm
not one who asked for handouts I'd
rather the homies like when they peep it
be like well I want to be a part of this
yeah that's better for me I don't want
no you know unless somebody said because
I feel like when you ask you know first
of all everybody's uncomfortable because
like bro like I'm sure a million people
asking you but if I show you what I'm
doing and you [__] with it then it's
genuine you [__] with it like you call
it hey this you don't you don't suck
come on the show do you um for you
musically like obviously being around 50
500 or nothing and their start because
they're Legends yeah Grammy
award-winning producers in essence they
was teenagers they got the school open
yeah they're doing they're doing so much
um who would you say just not even
necessarily somebody you know but like
sonically artist wise would you say have
the most influence on your sound oh like
probably shade Anita Baker and like um
oddly enough bro Chico DeBarge hey Chico
was a hoodie like certain people
um I do believe
Chico to bars yeah is the sun Daddy's
son's real dad right what one of Diddy's
sons of whom one of Diddy's Sons oh hell
no
actual father is Chico DeBarge you're
tripping I think you're talking about Al
B sure
you might be right and I think you're
talking about it's definitely I'll be
sure and Quincy are we sure kill me if I
let you rock with that
and this is why they need a [__] like
me and R B because we can't let that
ride
I love that just be like Frank Ocean pop
in every now and then and do great
artists dip out that'd be awesome that's
what I would like to do do you feel like
r b is like I feel like it's finally
kind of getting into a really good space
in terms of like
you know now when you turn on the radio
you'll hear like real r b records like
Coco Jones I see you as a big record
like there's tons of like records that
yeah money long time Leon Thomas like
come on bro let's be real R B's always
had a bunch of this is what happened
everybody talks about like arm I know
you were trying to avoid it but like you
know everybody thought all right r b
needed resuscitation I never thought
that I just think that
underground for a little bit well
underground just means it wasn't it
wasn't the pretty girl at the ball you
know what I mean like you're not when
you and I were growing up r b was on the
radio yeah because it was it's not the
pretty girl it's coming around it turned
30 years old and gaining away but the
reality is these young dudes these young
kids are finding creative ways to have
very interesting conversations around
that music like Brit is an R B artist
right
and it's when you hear sonder and you
hear those records you've never heard an
r b record like that you know when you
hear Leon Thomas go off you're like oh
that's that's like it's D'Angelo but
it's not like it's something and these
guys is really killing it man there's a
lot of competition and there's it's a
lot of saturation because of these are
love babies they're romance yeah
obviously shout out to Brent shout out
to uh scissor uh all them people and
they going crazy Sarah Ballinger got a
dope record on the radio right now
Eric's always been a great writer I feel
like we we lost the r b group
yeah well what we lost what no or just
groups in general there's no more groups
yeah people don't like because the music
industry sucks so much because he wants
to split up the pie no nobody because it
doesn't make any sense it's like what
happened to a jagged edge 23 there's no
more Jagged edges Drew Hills nothing
that's never gonna happen we're gonna
see singular artists for a long time
because it just makes more financial
sense it does one artist is a headache
and you know what it never hungry it
never actually works out no because
there's always once one person in the
group that's better than everyone else
well I think that's just indicative of
of capitalism in human culture gotta
stop the interview to tell you about our
family at Odd Socks that's right the
most comfortable socks in the world
ladies and gentlemen uh go to
oddsocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg calf or bootleg both promo codes
work you'll save 20 out at checkout uh
20 off these are the Odd Socks Basics
all right now you can get like a pack of
all black pack of all whites of course
they got all kind of crazy licenses WWE
Cheech and Chong they got Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles they got SpongeBob
SquarePants bruh look they got the
SpongeBob SquarePants Krabby Patty
draws
yeah now you don't want crabs but you do
want Mr crab's underwear because these
are fire all right so look go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code uh bootleg save 20 off the
checkout and uh yeah listen trust me
when I say most comfortable socks you'll
ever put on your [__] feet
and the most comfortable boxer briefs
what are we talking about man all right
autotoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off of checkout great gift and
and just treat yourself all right also
got a shout out to our family a King
Palm now if you guys want to know about
ping pong kingpong is all natural baby
yes all right we're talking about the
leader when it comes to uh tobacco-free
natural organic Leaf wraps if you're a
smoker a totor a straight west coaster
you know what I'm saying whatever you're
into King Palms they got it for you
what's great about
um these these are like one of the best
uh products that they sell now this is a
terpene infused tobacco-free leaf
and what's dope is you stuff your flour
into it
and then you press on the thingy you
know what I'm saying
and then you got flavor I'm going to
show you what it looks like when it's
stuffed
with some great tree from Jardin of
course
ah look at that
all right get that thing stuffed up
the tip has got that flavor in it uh
wherever you're at man make sure you
check out the uh
um you know they got the smoke shops
they got those on lock they got
7-Elevens on lock we only smoking out of
King Palms baby you already know what it
is and if you go to
kingpoms.com
kingpom.com kingpom.com
and you use the promo code bootleg Kev
you will save 50 off at checkout
half off at checkout fifty percent off
if you go to kingpom.com and use that
promo code the promo code is down below
go run it up try some of these flavors
too man the peach pineapple the
Strawberry Shortcake they just got so
much going on there's also all kinds of
dope smoking accessories you can get
half off y'all what are we talking about
save 50 off kingpom.com promo code below
it's either bootleg or bootleg have them
these promo codes got my head hurt try
both of them all right one of them get
you 50 off God damn it anyway let's get
back to the interview like I mean I
think about it that's just what it is so
right now we got blue bucks Clan who's a
Duo they're a Duo I thought it was three
[__] until I seen the two of them
[__] going crazy together they're
strong I love them uh
I mean Shoreline Mafia broke up oh Jeezy
goes solo and goes crazy but you know
why that happened you know SOB rbe they
broke up yeah everybody breaking that
fat boys break up now everybody wake up
but but the reality is bro that [__] was
destined to happen because like
everybody was told it's a cultural shift
also the kid first of all r b is a
reflection of whatever the state of Love
is in the culture the state of Love is
in Jeopardy so people are making
impressions of love right the music is
that we're making now is what we what we
wish was what we used to think love was
supposed to be but that's why Brent work
says it works because it's what love
looks like now which isn't a fairy tale
it's kind of toxic it's not a fairy tale
no more it's it's what it is now I think
that the pendulum is going to swing to
people Desiring romance again they're
gonna want those Lush voices they're
gonna want the hers of the world to go
crazy it's crazy yeah crazy but we're
going to start seeing more like I think
vocalists again and because
they're we I think women want to fall in
love again and even me I'm probably
gonna lean more into like romantic
records but I'm I can only make what I
know right now I'm dealing with trauma
so I'm talking about my past three [__]
I just happened to Chrome you know I'm
not even really a singer I'm a crooner
like there's a difference yeah there's a
real difference like like if we being
real like like I feel like Roddy rich is
like a crooner like he Roddy rich is is
a [__] who talks in Melody
one of the best
he's amazing
my favorite artist of all time he's made
legendary records karate's a legend bro
he's made legendary records I would say
like even like I know he's one of my
favorites a lot of people didn't like a
second album but I'm like it's so hard
for Roddy Rich to make bad music it's
yeah it's like but I think that's also
part of the problem like your sophomore
album after having that freshman of a
debut is crazy to have that song and
that was a weird timing too because the
Box popped off December 20 uh 2019 but
if we speak of the science right the
records that worked for Roddy were
Southern records at first until mustard
and him had that song so he was making
southern music yeah yeah and he's making
such music yeah he's making southern
music until until mustard you're from
L.A because I do feel like if you think
of the artists who have transcended
outside of
being West Coast artists right yeah they
don't make West Coast Music they don't
make West Coast like if we talking about
Kendrick you think of Schoolboy Q you
think Italian he was accepted on the
East Coast first right Tyler was
accepted by my kids in Middle America he
was doing records with ASAP Rocky yeah
kendrix Kendrick look at their concerts
at first they'll tell you they're con
like I'm sure that Johnny Rich doesn't
make traditionally West Coast no bro
because if you want to break out it is
like first of all even YG's first real
record was was was a southern record my
hitter a southern record literally by
your boy
record but it was a West Coast I was in
high school but my head had changed [__]
and that wasn't if we being real yes
it's his record but in real life we know
whose record that he is and by the way
that's no disrespect YG built that
ground for sure And My Crazy Life is a
classic
and he's sleeping with sweetie right now
so he's winning well let's let's not
talk about it why are we doing I just
because I'm I got to see these people I
don't want no smoke hey I'm just saying
don't put me in Nobody Business kid all
I'm saying is salute YG
sweetie well look you know crazy life
for real hey look shout out to my shout
out to to your boy doing this thing all
I can say is is that um we all know that
for you to break out just like for
rappers to be the biggest rappers on the
game for you to be top of the game you
have to make r b songs for girls we all
know that every topic that's it that's
the blueprint it's not a question right
the only way that Hove sees the top of
the charts is making a song with a
female demographic song yeah I think I
think back in the day that might have
been I think before the street because
now they're streaming artists who who
don't do that yeah they don't depend on
radio like you have you before you
really kind of had to have something to
appeal to women for radio correct but
now it's like if you just have a fan
base and like you're someone like Dirk
yeah you could just put out but let's
tons of crazy records but let's talk
about cancel stream let's talk about it
that's who cares A and B what is the
record that when he was moving in the
streets that women was like oh I can
listen to Dirt it was homebody
what's the female little baby record oh
you started us as close friends yeah
come on bro we could go look at the
numbers you're right you're right close
your friends first of all what is the
hottest the second if not the hottest
record of the new record is uh
his voice is crazy he's the like I think
everybody's like a variation like by the
way I love Friday he's amazing it's so
dramatic he's basically givion in the
weekend put together yeah like
everything just sounds like you've been
on that Khalid record he sounds crazy oh
bro Friday is my favorite artist like
when he dropped his mixtape I was like
bro I need that I need his voice is
crazy no and by the way my bad on
comparison I know new artists that's
that's his tone he's amazing his tone is
wild whatever he's doing is the thing
that he deserves to do I just think that
um stuff like that stands out but once
again I don't think you can avoid
I think I'm gonna be proven to be right
there even though the landscape has
changed because you can have a niche
market due to streaming um if you want
to win if you want if one ring to rule
them all on some Lord of the Rings [__]
gotta you gotta talk to the females
because even even Roddy like yeah things
change for him when he's that monster
record went crazy so for you because
we've seen it work with artists that
might be known for something like mac
Wilds is a great example you know
Tristan yeah that's my dog my first
Grammy nomination was on his album was
there for you like are you noticing at
least like you kind of
it's a little harder for you to earn
people's respect as an artist because
they perceive you as an actor oh no I
don't care because I was a street [__]
first right so like my respect doesn't
come from and honestly Tristan's a
project baby first yeah like people
don't know that like he just likes r b
music so he does r b [__] and he got an
r b voice he can really sing so that's
what he liked but if we talk about how
the market wants to receive you of
course they're gonna they want to see
you how they want to see you and I've
been blessed enough and lucky enough to
the kind of music that I think I'm
making might be easier to digest with
the people who watch me on screen
because I'm talking about past
situations that are not too far away
from the stuff from the stuff that I
kind of am in the world of now if I go
make a pop record and I'm making records
like like um like what's the face you
just mentioned her um the one who uh who
had that big record the female artist
that came out of nowhere uh songwriter
what's her name you just set a record
what's her name she just had the big
record songwriter all right the hours
remember she had that that super poppy
record that came out right after right
like didn't connect right but that's not
but if I did that maybe my audience is
that's not who following me right now
right the people who are following you
you're making the type of music that
they might be like oh [__] oh yeah it's
kind of hard like this may not because
all I got to do really bro I look at
everything as an opportunity so like all
I gotta do is not suck if I don't suck
people will be like even if they want to
hate they like okay I don't like this on
like that I'm like but if I keep going
and it keeps working it at some point
bro you're gonna have to at least
respect the grind and you know what's
crazy is like
when you used to watch movies as like
like when I was a kid and you were
probably were probably similar in age
the guys who would be like rapping on
the movies or on the shows would also
have music in the soundtrack that's a
fact almost all of the time so if you
get like a like the Above the Rim Yeah
the soundtrack was hard the soundtrack
were crazy and you'd always be like oh
the guy in the movies got a song on the
[__] soundtrack that's a fact so are
you well I mean everyone's out of work
but like obviously you're killing it in
the TV game yeah are you actively
like is is the how different is the
movie Hustle and the TV Hustle the
difference is well that's the thing is
even the rider strike is about
more so
TV writers pay and TV writers rooms and
how they're being kind of like finessed
out of a bag because of these predatory
practices the T the movie dudes are kind
of like we ain't tripping we ain't
tripping unless to say like you know
what I'm saying this is artificial it's
not official intelligence it's like we
good and not but that's not really but
we're all in solidarity I'm just telling
you the truth like so when I talk to
because I'm I got people like who are
Executives who are film Executives TV
Executives I'll talk to everybody and
people [__] with me so I'll talk to them
I'll be like what's the real you know
and everybody's kind of like well we're
just waiting to see how it plays out
um movies is you write a speck you know
you could get hired on assignment to
write a spec there's less steps than in
the TV deal when you do a TV show you
got to do
um you got to do a blueprint before you
buy it to the treatment before you even
get to the pilot there's like five steps
oh [__] and they get to parcel out the
money
a little bit more and also you're not
getting paid as much unless you're
popping so movies I started off Writing
Movies you know I was like New Jack City
too on a movie because there's a budget
already
this is development here hey look like
here here's here's a certain amount of
money right and to develop now you still
have steps you still have to do a first
draft second draft rewrite you're
they're old that and they don't even
have to pay you for the second steps if
they don't want to if they don't feel
like you doing what you're supposed to
do they'll just give it to another
writer you'll get second credit and you
don't get as much money on the royalties
or back in that's if you get blessed
enough to have a movie get made but with
TV writers they kind of I think they
hold they they kind of string you on a
little bit more and the money is
parceled out a little bit longer and
it's more of a grind it's more of a blue
collar work and um so that's why it's
kind of like it's more of a daily thing
too yeah writing every week you're in
writer's rooms and it's the same thing
with the acting with an acting contract
if unless you're on well I guess network
isn't dead but network is not the
primary thing anymore it's streaming is
like Netflix you know you used to be you
could be they're they're the most if you
ever looked at the highest paid actors
it would always be like five people off
in in CIS six like right or friends or
something right it'd be something crazy
on some hit TV show right because
they're doing 22 Episodes in each
episode of getting paid a hundred to six
hundred thousand dollars you know it's
but you're doing so many episodes and
then you do TV TV is just instead of
eight months out your year you do excuse
me TV is like you're doing eight months
out the year to six months out the year
to shoot something but for a movie maybe
you're doing three to six or maybe two
yeah and then also like if you think
about Netflix you're like for every
stranger things there's like a hundred
other shows that aren't
on that level and they just go it's one
or two seasons and they're just throwing
bread they trying to see what his
they're going off algorithm and [__] and
that's cool and but for me as it relates
to me as a person who's trying to create
it's the same solution it all of these
pieces can change bro this is all just
distractions for me because at the end
of the day bro it's the name of the game
of what you're doing right here you work
at an institution and you know that your
Leverage is limited there just like head
new my Leverage is limited they don't
work there anymore all right they run my
show oh they said they Syndicate my show
but I I record my show at the crib or
here and what does that mean you pay for
it right because the simple conversation
I put up I put up the risk and then this
the show they just they just picked up
my show so I'm on in all these markets
and I don't work for nobody so when you
ask me what's the difference I say the
only difference for me is what my mom
and my daddy told my mama my daddy told
me which is hey look if you pay for it
mm-hmm you own it yeah you can tell
people what to do next time
from your perspective from somebody
who's done so much in the entertainment
industry what would be your advice for
somebody who maybe has a good idea or
maybe has put together like a great idea
for a pilot or like a concept for a TV
show
but they have zero relationships in the
industry what would be your advice to
somebody like that how to break in how
to get their script in the right hands
how to try to get some sort of movement
in uh in in an industry that to me it
just even living here the movie industry
the TV industry it feels unpenetratable
and I'm sure a lot of people feel that
way about the music industry it's the
same thing everything it's all the same
[__] the only difference is that like
there's more miracles than music there's
more happy accidents in music because
the threshold to entry the barrier to
entry is a little lower yeah it's a lot
easier to go straight to the marketplace
yeah because you could just like record
in your bedroom SoundCloud and you're
amazing you're up but with movies it
costs so much more to have a product
that can compete with the other products
that are on the assembly right so what I
would say is this first of all the
simple thing is what you're doing bro
it's like same thing that was told to me
that I knew to do just like go make your
own [__] collaborate with people who are
your super you're who you're who are
your peer group and and keep to
bettering your craft and invest in
yourself and keep it manageable so that
you're not encroaching a ball in your
personal life if you have
responsibilities if you don't have
responsibilities roll the [__] dice
while you go in if you do have
responsibilities please do not like
unless you are unless you like Selena
daddy and you like [__] it like and you
gotta partner this with you like you
know I don't I don't I have someone
bankrolled their own pilot right what
can they do with that when they put it
on YouTube but they shop it around with
an agent you could do that that may work
I think that it's a low likelihood I
would say take the same money that you
would spend on a 60 page pilot which is
going to be you know let's say however
much money you would spend on that and
spend that same amount of money on a on
a three to six or seven minutes short
that can display your idea or the
fraction of your ideas so that you can
go get other people to invest what you
need to go do what they need to do
people just need to see the idea look
cool and work so it's kind of like
getting a record deal you have to find a
production company that believes in the
idea yeah to bankroll how it should be
done or you bankroll it like I found out
with a lot of artists even quicker them
like I heard that they was recording in
a basement and they took a little demo
tape to whomever and the person was like
okay this is something we'll put more
money in it because it looks like it may
work I'll invest Equity with you same
thing me and my team doing so it's all
the same bro it's business is business
right if you invest in your own [__]
when it works you get all the funds but
you also got to take the risk of falling
on your ass I don't advise people
because I don't know their personal
situations all I can say is if you want
to do it this is how you go about it you
got a bank on yourself and you got to
work with people who are both slightly
above you and and near you so that you
can both improve and keep and keep your
community going that's dope uh June 23rd
your AP is coming Street Journal volume
one got some cool features on it also
got some dope music Sticks and Stones is
out right now that's making motion we
own like three or four you just shot a
music video too yeah yeah today for both
of them songs your music videos got to
be crazy right oh you're gonna see it
before we get up out of here it's gonna
go crazy yeah
um anything else you have on the way uh
obviously outside of music I'm sure
right under strike is kind of putting a
bit of a well listen we still got the
third season of Raising Canaan coming
out it's already done yeah we've been
done that
y'all now next summer we don't know
what's going on I think that's coming
out in the fall or something like that
they pushed it back uh don't quote me
but yeah it's just but for right now
anything else in the can that you film
that's on the way oh them season two I
wrote on I wrote on them season two so
that's coming but I would still say the
music right now is Gonna Save
everybody's life I can go take care of
my family so do that go listen go
straight let's go stream it all out uh
and of course uh go check out the
freestyle we recorded too except for me
YouTube videos oh yeah yeah that's gonna
be it all right man thank you for making
me thanks for making me rap kid
appreciate you you're welcome because
now I'm gonna be rapping very just keep
crooning
appreciate you pulling up man all right
yes sir [__] with you hey appreciate
y'all watching another interview brought
to you by our good Folks at hardean now
listen y'all when you're in Las Vegas
you get in that [__] Uber you land at
the airport hit that taxi tell him to
take you to hard Dean the number one
premium cannabis dispensary in the
[__] world y'all I'm telling you you
walk in they treat you like a king or a
queen or whatever you're into all right
they got the craziest selection to
premium cannabis you'll see period
anyway let alone in Las Vegas but just
anywhere all right not only can you go
get the best tree you'll get the best
experience the best customer service the
best bud tenders you walk in the hard
Dean and that [__] just smells amazing
saying they got their own [__] scent
literally you get into my car I got a
bottle of it my car smells like Harding
because it's just the best [__] place
um go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas
Harding underscore Las Vegas go to their
website
hardinglasvegas.com all right when you
go you're in Vegas you pull up tell them
I sent you they're gonna take care of
you the right way all right look they
got these things in there man these Moon
Rock uh pre-rolls that I just had that
just absolutely melted my face off
shout out to hard Dean all right you
gotta go [__] with hard Dean man Harding
underscore Las Vegas uh thank you all
man I love these guys they're like
family to us and hey we're gonna drop
another interview soon if you're
watching this you're at the end of the
interview though much love